there is a republican-controlled county
in Arizona that is Cochise County or it
may be pronounced goat cheese it's not
completely clear to me and they are
refusing to certify the election as the
Associated Press is reporting Republican
officials in a rural Arizona county
refused yesterday to certify the 2022
election here we go again it's the same
stuff one this is the sequel my friends
a decision that was quickly challenged
in court by the state's top election
official now I want to make an important
distinction here
Steve Bannon and some others when it
comes to 2020
continue to talk about decertification
we have to decertify the election there
is no such process there's just it
doesn't exist
this here is a different situation where
they are saying let's not certify
certification is indeed a process and
the Secretary of State Katie Hobbs is
the Democratic candidate who won and
will be the governor
she has asked the judge to order County
officials to Canvas the election which
she said is an obligation under the law
so there's a couple different things
going on here and of course no matter
what is going on these right Wingers
will come up with some reason why they
are actually correct and everything is
absolutely right that they want to do
when they want to do it but anytime
there's a different perspective then it
must be somebody who's doing something
wrong it's fraud it's whatever the case
is going to be
the practice that they are getting here
is to refuse to certify a federal
election it's important to understand
that these are always trial balloons for
the next thing and refusing to certify a
state election at the county level is a
trial for a state refusing to certify a
federal election at the state level if
this were to happen or in any way even a
fraction of it were to happen they would
use it as precedent for the future
that's number one secondly this isn't
legal okay it is absolutely correct to
go to court to try to force
certification and these are folks who
have been given a duty a task an
election has taken place the ballots
have been counted now you have to
certify there is no analogy to ban and
saying well there's a duty to decertify
decertification isn't a thing these
elected officials have no duty to
decertify elections you're you're put in
a certain position
County Board of Elections you have to
certify they're not doing it it's a
legal issue that's why they're going to
court now I know where they are going to
ultimately find the certificate and it's
going to be of course in Hunter Biden's
laptop or on Hillary hard drives emails
right no uh I believe that the grounds
here that they are claiming are of
course completely imaginary this is
going to be certified and then they are
going to say this is proof
that they stole it because they came in
and forced us to certify something that
shouldn't have been certified of course
it's simply their job to certify this is
still potentially very dangerous because
almost no matter what ultimately happens
with this attempt not to certify they
are going to say well here's the next
thing that now we have to do at the next
election which happens to be 2024
presidential where Arizona along with a
handful of other states could determine
who's the next president of the United
States very scary stuff